je suis amusé à chercher mon sosie a
vraiment tout votre sosie je vais à
combler italien non je vous jure que
c'est vrai regardez on à la photo de
vous voilà la vie lui pas il est
apparemment il vend des fetwas vous
benhaim benhaim coucher votre sosie
aussi à je vous jure que c'est vrai mad
men en quoi ce crâne pierre avec vous
non je vous jure dansaert alors benhaim
ont regardé benhaim away c'est une star
de tennis
alors si on a gardé ses potes je suis
pas martinez cantus à martinez avait
gagné roland garros je crois bien celle
ci ferait pour l'essentiel avait gagné
roland garros une année mais voilà vous
êtes tous si belles toutes les deux jean
michel maire tient et chez votre sosie
aussi non je vous jure que c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous fout pas franchement mais
c'est vrai oui tiens on a le saunier de
maxime aussi le magazine maxim gay ni
regarder il est un globe trotter qui
permette regarde on avait aussi non
[Rires]
attendez attendez
oui qu'est-ce qui se passe non mais ça y
est elle est devenue complètement soit
la grille à tokyo on ne la contrôle plus
elle m'appelle sur mon portable je vois
un numéro et mais qu'est ce tu veux le
métal maintenant je ferai pas cacher
totalement d'accord mais en tout cas on
est méchant qu'on lui a demandé si vous
n'êtes pas mieux en extérieur dans les
revenus
on est ainsi
[Applaudissements]
et c'est bon à savoir si c'est à dire
quand vous nous sortez on vous appelle
pour rentrer mais faut être sympa les
saints pas là beaucoup de forfaits les
sympas les chérir garde a donné on a le
sosie de christine à regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors gbagbo les attendait pour bon beh
hammam était directeur une photo de son
père alors pourquoi je vous dis pourquoi
tant de me mais on se voulait que vous
dites avec malik bentalha et franck
gastambide sont évasives et je vous dit
tout oui c'est ma liberté n va ne vient
pas de moi m'a dit qu'il a voulu dire et
il a dit le père de benjamin castaldi
on dirait benjamin castaldi mais qui
s'est cognée
ah et boudet on a t'on sosie aussi
bouder oui c'est facile
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est masterchef à kelly osbourne ait
choisi de cali on est saisi de kelly ah
ouais alors moi c'est pas mon délire
mais chantal et coordonnée pour courbet